ai suonatori un po sballati
la maledizione della fascia ro.la siete
mai stati sorpresi a fare sesso orale
sotto mi schiaccia questo pulsante
capitato
ciao ragazzi benvenuti nella puntata di
vita buttata oggi mi faccio punte con le
karma b ragazze
è un piacere anche perché non siete da
sole troviamo leon
piccolo portafortuna cosa vi posso
offrire dal mio mappamondo delle
meraviglie ragazze io vorrei una vodka
un'acqua prove in acqua
[Applauso]
lo so no sta dicendo mamma non ancora
propongo di partire subito a bombazza
con una cosa che ci siamo promessi
professor c'è stata una cosa che è stata
promessa io non credo che abbiamo fatto
qui carriera facendo pesare sia chiaro
io sono incazzata nera cosa perché in
tanti anni di carriera mai nessuno che
mi abbia chiesto favori sessuali in
cambio di un lavoro ma vuol dire cosa mi
mancava mi sono incazzato con tutte le
persone che ricevono avete presente
cazzi nei dm mezzo
guarda se me lo dicevi prima mentre mi
cambiano
uno scatto al molo ragazze una soletta
sì grazie
my lady
partiamo con una puntata di vita buttata
[Musica]
sicura di voler raccontare questa cosa o
pendino che meramente scorta possiamo
dire che è un'amica
dall'esperienza in sé è stata molto
divertente
il dopo che è stato leggermente awkward
neanche sgradevole ti dico allora ero
giovane per questo ragazzo si fa quello
che si deve certo punto nel c il post
orgasmico tra una chiacchiera e l'altra
lui mi dà alla domanda che non mi doveva
fare ma tu che il lavoro fai e io che
già facevo la tranquilla
ma
guarda tu e lui mese mario studio da
infermiere a proposito
a proposito già che c'ero ho dato una
controllatina alla prostata tutto a
posto
non ci credo è successo veramente
devo dire che è stato divertente perché
è stato dentista io oppure pensa a mi
ricordo di aver pensato è bravo
quest'ora gara e invece era
professionista
ciao a tutti racconto della mia
ottimissimo state d'amore dura da cinque
sei mesi dove alcuni di queste storie ci
diciamo amorevolmente ti amo giorno dopo
lui conosce 10 dopo ancora mi dice non
ho conosciuto un'altra persona molto
interessante ciao feste della borgata
stiamo scherzando
ma
scusate ma prima si è avvicinato a noi
fa posso toccarle
[Applauso]
e allora se lo vuoi per andare in bagno
ma quello che la via melo riposo tecnico
invece tornando al al messaggio secondo
voi non era amore quella cosa che
trovava ma semplicemente questo
trasporto è veramente adesso ne abbiamo
viste di tutti i colori sai cosa io
credo sinceramente lo di quanti con un
po di dispiacere che ci sia una
scarsissima educazione sentimentale
quando tu hai dei sentimenti che non
riesci a codificare li esprime maniera
anche un po bruciata la maldestra anche
in sincera non dico che quel ragazzo
fosse falso quando gli addetti a ci
credeva inquadrare questo ci crediamo
però chiaramente non poteva essere un ti
amo e poi ci andrebbe anche un bel
distinguo fra innamoramento infatuazione
e amore basta questa profondità torniamo
a lei
possiamo ascoltare un altro audio
gentilmente stavano gianmarco prometto
che sarà sintetica
io e l'amore non ho mai avuto storia e
storie in costanza di temi che ma una
cosa curiosa sia il mio fidanzatino di
quinta elementare sia ragazzo che mi si
dichiarò in quarta superiore sia quello
che mi va di rete o altri in mano di
università dopo poco tempo da l'avevamo
incontrata hanno fatto come i now it
come gay praticamente devo capire ancora
stata un'edizione extra alcune ragazze
però ce l'hanno questa croce ragazzi
anche quando ha detto questa rossa in te
ti capitava parlare di lei presenti
anche anche tu
alcune ragazze ce la nostra è una
maledizione compiuto la maledizione
della croce rola
quindi
vai su pornhub e di vita
secondo il dizionario zanichelli
93 parola significa una persona che ama
frequentare e una donna che ama
frequentare le persone citate
c'è un pelo in bocca nel mio
socio un pelo in bocca ma quello della
famiglia va bene ora niente abbiamo ma
cosa dire il frattempo faccio un e film
maker e film che ancora la cosa è già
pazza ma cosa riferimento preciso per me
va bene noi diciamo proprio a te così
già pazza
ho letto che usciremo vivi da questa
puntata
come fa ridere che io questo gesto
disposizione vicino alla bocca
io so che c'è una sorpresa per noi in
una sorpresa musicale
che fissa al fatto sapere che ho
dimenticato le mutande contenuti
[Risate]
siete una bella sorpresa un altro ci
sono arrivata con scusate siete arrivate
con una scatola che meno posso farla che
era così ora io capisco che
potesse sembra una chitarra ma mi
aspetto che sia dell'altro qualora c'è
una chitarra sono contento di ascoltarla
allora è una chitarra noi abbiamo
portate me l'ha lanciata dalla regia
grazie
la vicenda è corretto ma mica perché la
banca al contrario ci credo che c'è il
avambraccio destro con di svilupparsi
noi facciamo tutto dal vivo nostro
spettacolo racconta della nostra sia
anche perché da morte sarebbe abbastanza
magnifico spettacolo che stai un'ora e
mezza morta ma
succederà qualcosa magari del secondo
tempo c'era letto in posizione non lo so
spero
[Musica]
e noi raccontiamo un percorso musicale
di tutte queste dire che ci hanno
cresciuto cioè da quando eravamo
ragazzini bull i dati su tutte le nostre
storie che un po tutti abbiamo infatti e
tra queste c'era la bertè chiaramente
ovviamente la prima che la casa perché è
una tuttora una guerriera una donna che
se n'è sempre sbattuta e coesione di
tutto quanto e che quindi abbiamo
mangiato con questa canzone
prima di cominciare la ghiera la regia
siccome non era uno scherzo che ha
dimenticato le mutande contenitive va
bene così si vede e non si capisce cos'è
questo qualcosa in più che hanno le vive
ai suonatori un po sballati ai balordi
come me
a chi non sono mai piaciute
a chi non ho incontrato aspetta che
questa corte difficile
e chissà mai perché
hai dimenticato
ai primi finiti
[Applauso]
[Musica]
anche se guarda nello specchio del mondo
di più
anche non a uno specchio
e comunque non per questo non ce la fa
più
ha lavorato
anche stato troppo sole
[Musica]
anche ha cercato la maniera
domanda mai
faccia che una sera dedicato a chi ha
paura
saldi
guai
dedicate ai cattivi
[Musica]
così cattivi non solo
intanto si avesse insieme
maradona
[Applauso]
[Musica]
all'una
[Applauso]
e mia giornata
è
stato uno dei momenti più alti di vita a
buttare cioè non ci voleva ben sa come è
stata vietata ma mai veramente molto
grave grazie mille con una sorpresa per
voi dall'argentina a questo punto direi
di partire col segmento
[Musica]
che cosa facciamo la linea
domande domande
temi questi
ragazzi di 61 funziona partendo da me
come se l'avesse capito
[Risate]
di essere un signore prima le donne ed
allora nessun corso giacomo noi giocando
il futuro
grazie per avermi cesena rilegge la
prossima puntata di vita buttata se
potete fare sesso in qualsiasi luogo del
mondo dove sarebbe
davanti a tutti senza 20 rman è mai
davvero già fatto su quella poltrona
non c'è un posto davvero l'abbia fatto
[Applauso]
questo vale sai che non c'hanno non era
in mente un cazzo di oscar
[Applauso]
qual è una delle vostre fantasie
sessuali preferite il meccanico
[Musica]
meccanico perché ci hanno quella tuta
capito che sa se apre
bene schiacciate allenatore
[Musica]
io sono molto più basic bastano quelle
del ma del meccanico al camino
basterebbe 5 che abbia un atteggiamento
denigrante
fa sesso con me capito
scusate ma fantasia si presuppone che tu
non le abbia realizzate
la sauna peccato che non possa dire lo
stesso
noi siamo qui
chiederò sessuali e una cosa che non
necessita come ha spiegato davanti al
mio programma è sottotitolato per gli
eterosessuali
[Risate]
tramontana per eterosessuale sta dicendo
[Applauso]
voglio fare dice vogliamo uscire adesso
tu mi schiaccia questo pulsante capitato
inginocchia ti schiaccia pool casi ad
abusare con data hai capito che ho
sentito bene vari sufficiente per fare
felice il vostro fegato ma ripreso anche
a me hai capito la
mostra si che aspetto è il che suono e
mettete quando il sesso è fatto bene ma
mi hanno chiamato l'ambulanza di angela
pelagonia
basate le giocate c'è qualcosa di non
sessuale che cita il bonifico
ma cosa ne sessuale
che non è sessuale
battute per ed omosessuali
ditemi qualcosa di sexy con un accento
sardo e il mio fidanzato sardo
dai
vieni qui equa ed
equa in che lingua e guastalla
callara perché forza di colpi di fatto
così ok va bene così successori taek
arrivano da giocare va bene così
[Risate]
siete mai stati sorpresi a fare sesso
ci sono delle tipologie di abbigliamento
che trovate altamente ero a tutti i
pinocchietti
lazio mia tuta grigia con sotto e bossi
avete mai fantasticato su qualcun altro
mentre facevate
quando ha spiegato sulla persona con
questo progetto
con quante persone avete fatto 7 ciao
una trentina quarantina
nella società giornata se fosse pulito
allora
l'hanno capito la domanda aveva capito
la domanda
ricordate il miglior orgasmo della
vostra vita sì stamattina si si si
faceva anche così in realtà assistiti
e qual è il maggior numero di volte in
cui avete fatto sesso in un unico giorno
un numero normale insomma
una 24
sta dicendo
no di già vivo da raccontare questo
episodio di quando mio figlio
appuntamento queste ragazze in estate
c'erano deve fare la passeggiata qualche
birra a un certo punto erano della
giostra che gente gira a un certo punto
vista o fissando sotto ma viene senso
della parola
vedo il terrore dei suoi occhi io mi
copro
lui puntualmente mette la sua mano sopra
il
insomma avete capito e sapreste dire
bagnato e mi stavo sotterrando cioè io
23 anni che hanno fatto da base del
genere volevo morire e niente adesso
stiamo insieme da cinque anni e abbiamo
una figlia
sono confuso non so voi lo so che lei
era confusa
sono a malta informazione in questa sera
tardi tanto diciamo subito che abbiamo
riconosciuto la voce di lavinia
io volevo dire a questa ragazza adesso
sposata a quanto ho capito con cui si
guarda ecco volevo dire la linea di
controllare con c'e niente di male ma di
controllare bene quali categorie di
youporn guarda questo ragazzo perché se
si è sposato dopo questa disavventura
ammesso casualmente la mano sul sedile
bagnato e poi si è asciugato magari la
fronte
probabilmente no feih1 pietà non sono
casuali la cosa positiva è che non abbia
detto che se te
cosa che mi sarei aspettata giungere
al meno male avevo sete di squadra
risponde così dire che sente totti
guarda un po vabbè e ragazze e con
questo che dopo sette giorni di shooting
prema diventeranno sette puntate
speciali di di vita buttata io vi
ringrazio di grave per essere state mie
ospiti grazie ma grazie a te bisogno
perché avevamo avuto troppa serietà come
si dice eterosessualità
capito allora siamo noi che ti
ringraziamo perché questa è stata una
delle chiacchierate più divertente che
abbiamo mai fatto non credere a quelli
che ti dicono che lo diciamo tutti
perché malignità che si è registrato
siamo in videocomunicazione diciamo è
stata la nigeria
xix secolo ma lei perché noi diciamo
solo no e poi soprattutto devo dirvi che
con cui mi sono mai divertita tanto ma
adesso ho capito perchè perchè non ho
mai creduto nelle altre interviste
nostra diciamo
marcia avanti rispetto agli altri
programmi perbenisti noi ci vedremo
sempre qui non so quando ma comunque
prima o poi accadrà da ragazzi
[Musica]